"THE FIVE," "SPECIAL REPORT" IS
UP NEXT.
>> GOOD EVENING, WELCOME TO
WASHINGTON ON MIKE EMANUEL IN
FOR BRET BAIER.
CHRISTMAS IS OVER AND HANUKKAH
ENDS THIS EVENING.
IF MEMBERS OF BOTH A CHRISTIAN
AND JEWISH FACE WERE UNDER
ATTACK OVER THE WEEKEND.
FOX TEAM'S COVERAGE OF
CORRESPONDENT JEFF IN TEXAS
WHERE A GUNMAN OPENED FIRE IN
THE CHURCH KILLING TWO BUT FOR
THE PARISHIONER WITH THE GUN
COULD HAVE BEEN MUCH WORSE.
CORRESPONDENT JULIE INTERNET
LOOKS AT THE RISE OF
ANTI-SEMITISM AND RELIGIOUS HATE
AND WHAT PRESIDENT TRUMP IS
DOING ABOUT IT.
WE BEGIN WITH CORRESPONDENT
JACQUI HEINRICH WHERE THE
ACCUSED AND THE LATEST ATTACK
AND NOW FACES FEDERAL HATE
CRIMES.
A GOOD EVENING, JACKIE.
>> GOOD EVENING, MY, THE CASE
NOW FACES FEDERAL HATE CRIME
CHARGES AS A PRIVATE ARMED
SECURITY GUARDS STAND OUTSIDE
THE SYNAGOGUE TONIGHT AFTER THE
COUNTY CALLED AN EXTRA HELP.
>> THE STATE POLICE AND
DETECTIVES.
THEY WILL BE GOING TO THE
DIFFERENT -- AND A VERY, VERY
MENACING OMNIPRESENT TRUCK.
>> JEWISH PEOPLE IN MUNCIE
NEW YORK FIELD IT IS NECESSARY
AFTER A RAMPAGE AT A RABBI'S
HOME ON THE SUMMIT THAT NIGHT OF
HANUKKAH.
POLICE SAY 38-YEAR-OLD THOMAS
BURST IT IN WITH A MACHETE AND
SAID NO ONE IS LEAVING.
INCLUDING THE RABBI'S ON, FIVE
PEOPLE COME UP BEFORE TRYING TO
GET INTO THE SYNAGOGUE NEXT
DOOR.
IF THEY CHASE THE MAN OUT
THROWING TABLES AND CHAIRS AND
GOT HIS LICENSE PLATE.
INVESTIGATORS ALLEGEDLY FOUND
DISTURBING EVIDENCE IN THIS CAR
AND A JOURNAL WITH ANTI-SEMITIC
STATEMENTS AND REFERENCES TO AND
ADOLF HITLER.
IF THEY ALSO SAY THOMAS
RESEARCHED OTHER JEWISH TEMPLES
ONLINE.
>> SCORES OF PAPERS WHICH
FRANKLY SHOW THE WRANGLING
FRANKLY SHOW THE RRANGLING
FRANKLY SHOW THE RAMNGLING
FRANKLY SHOW THE RAMBLLING
FRANKLY SHOW THE RAMBLINNG
FRANKLY SHOW THE RAMBLINGS OF A
DISTURBED INDIVIDUAL.
>> HE VOWED TO CRACK DOWN ON THE
ALARMING UPTICK IN ANTI-SEMITIC
ATTACKS.
SINCE DECEMBER 23RD, THERE HAS
BEEN ONE ANTI-SEMITIC ATTACK
EACH DAY, ON CHRISTMAS DAY I'M
IN A TRADITIONAL CLOTHING WAS
PUNCHED IN THE FACE IN BROOKLYN.
IF THE DAY AFTER SOMEONE BEAT
THE JEWISH MOTHER OVER THE HEAD
WITH A BAT.
THE CASES ALREADY BACK ON THE
SCREED AN END NEW YORK'S NEW
REFORM LAWS SHE'S NOT ENOUGH
ABOUT THE RIGHT TO BE HELD
BEFORE TRIAL AND SHE IS ACCUSED
OF PUNCHING AND YELLING SLURS
AND THREE ORTHODOX WOMEN.
PRESIDENT TRUMP CALLED FOR UNITY
AGAINST ANTI-SEMITISM BUT THE
SUSPECT SAYS IT'S NOT WHAT IT
SEEMS AND CLAIMING MY CLAIMING
THOMAS IS NOT WHAT
THOMAS IS NOT IHAT
THOMAS IS NOT ITAT
THOMAS IS NOT IT SEEMS.
HE WAS HOSPITALIZED MANY TIMES
BECAUSE OF HIS AGE, HIS MOTHER
COULD ONLY DO SO MUCH TO GET HIM
HELP.
>> HE'S ALWAYS BEEN A GENTLE
GIANT WITH MENTAL ILLNESS.
>> INVESTIGATORS HAVE NOT
COMMENTED ON THE REPORT THAT THE
SUSPECT IN CONNECTION TO ANOTHER
STABBING AT THE SYNAGOGUE AND
THE VERY SAME TOWN LAST MONTH.
MIKE.
>> Mike: JACKIE, HOW DO THE
FEDERAL HATE CRIME CHARGES
IMPACT THE POTENTIAL SENSE?
>> MARK, HE CAN BE PROSECUTED AT
THE STATE LEVEL FOR THE
ATTEMPTED MURDER CHARGES AND
THEY CARRY THEIR OWN SET OF
PENALTIES AND AT THE SAME TIME
HE CAN BE PROSECUTED AT THE
FEDERAL LEVEL FOR THE HATE CRIME
CHARGES AND DEPENDING ON THE
SURVEY ARE PROSECUTIONS THAT
THEY PURSUE, IT COULD BE
DIFFERENT PENALTIES IN THE
DOCUMENTS SHOW THAT THERE ARE
LESS OPTIONS OPEN AND THEY CAN
PURSUE BODILY INJURY WHICH
CARRIES A PENALTY OF UP TO 20
YEARS.
OR THEY COULD GO FOR THE
ATTEMPTED TO KILL.
THAT MEANS HE COULD BE PUT AWAY